je n'ai même pas pu s'arrêter bien de
rien je vous demande de vous arrêter
alors vu oui vous avez déclaré dans
vital
vite envie tard en octobre 99 ouhlala je
ris de tout même de la mort qui moi j'ai
dit ça on sait très bien qu'en est il
trois ans plus ça dépend de la mort de
keats
charlie barr dont vous avez déclaré dans
dans le même numéro du magazine vous
avez déclaré mon pire défaut c'est
d'être trop généreux parfois même je
suis très con way
qu'en est il aujourd'hui aujourd'hui je
crois que je suis toujours aussi con
e
sur lui je crois que vous êtes mûr
pour une nouvelle interview qui
s'appelle poule à voilà quand je taperai
dans mes mains je crains tu seras
d'accord
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai très très peu
série
a perdu là jacques martin
caceres attention quand je taperai dans
mes mains tu seras le mime marceau super
énervés attention
pas sophie marceau
d'accord quand tu as toi ok j'ai pas
fini
et était très énervé
attention
quand je taperai dans les mains tu seras
sait bien que philippe de villiers dans
un club échangiste devant le
distributeur de capotes attention craque
l'ancien record je taperai dans les
mains tu sauras un gagnant du loto
attention
ouais
quoi
[Applaudissements]
quand je taperai dans les mains tu seras
un gagnant du loto qui a perdu le ticket
non c'est pas possible
trop dur pour moi
oh non j'ai vu
des corps de roger
c'était fou
tous ses biens je suis je fais quatre
ans de dexter studio which has gone et
ancien monsieur lui quand je taperai
dans mes mains tu seras un serial-killer
temps et peu de noirs
attention quand je t'ai appris dans les
mains tu seras benjamin casse tête
quand ça formidable après les chansons
les millions
attention quand je taperai dans les
mains tu seras dieu
voilà
je vous ai compris
charlie wi quand je te ferai dans les
mains rigole d'avancé taper dans les
mains tu sauras
lady di
bon je taperai dans mes matches sera
charli
cousine germaine
ça va pour lui enlever
j'aime tout le monde
et je suis bien sur france 3 attention
charlie quand j'étais à prêt dans mes
mains charlie tu seras à lui
près le poids le but vécu
moi charest
[Applaudissements]
pendant les guignols voilà voilà où en
est la france on bouge pendant le single
voilà
il est temps que sarkozy mette un peu
d'ordre à tout ça mon âme et oui avec
devedjian oui
bien omar quand je te ferai dans mes
mains tu seras
bien lescure
je mange
quand je taperai dans les mains tu seras
xavier couture
hockey atome a ont un besoin
d'augmentation d'une famille nombreuse à
nourrir
et ça va être effectif dans les
prochains jours
c'est pour vous omar quand je taperai
dans les mains tu sauras jean marie le
pen le soir du premier tour
non me ferais du fémur coin ne peut le
faire
mission
vous êtes un homme malsain
un technocrate vous pressez pas la
france métal ou acculé de dettes
surendettés
non c'est bien
et l'a fait
bien
quand je taperai dans les mains tu seras
michael jackson
et vingt gamins de présents a pu faire
une manif gernot battu
mais qu'est ce qu'elle a ma
gueule
très bien que la cravate c'est quand je
serai prêt dans les mains tu seras
monsieur riche en beaux de tours
il est décédé ce matin ce n'est pas bien
de se moquer de moi
je vais faire je peux faire madame michu
d'être un peu triste non nous mari meurt
ce matin et cet après midi
à tient au mas quand je taperai dans les
mains tu feras benjamin qu'à celle des
civils et que félicien se bat à mains
nues contre un grizzly tapez 1
par contre si vous voulez que les signes
se fasse prendre par le gazouillis
c'est ça
j'étais après le match sera dieu
faire là le jean c'est vrai oui trop de
croyance en un an pas de trucs sur dieu
il a même moore a ses limites il a peur
de dieu oui c'est vers le diable les
méthodes
attention
quand je taperai dans le marbre tu seras
fred
inité lieu
[Applaudissements]
qu'après le match sera omar
comme ça non c'est à vous la tension
quand je taperai dans mes mains vous
serez thierry ardisson
voit le nouveau thierry ardisson le pote
de guy bedos j'accueille mon ami de
toujours guy bedos
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux